نعم يعني الساعات المقبله هي ساعات حاسمه
في عمر المشهد السياسي والمشهد الامني
والمشهد
الاجتماعي هنا في السودان ذلك لاهميه
ولحساسيه هذه التحركات لقوات الدعم السريع
وتمركز الجيش وانفتاح الجيش في منطقه مروي
العسكريه بالولايه الشماليه هذه التطورات
واجزاء ما قال به الجيش السوداني صباح هذا
اليوم من ان البلاد تمر بمنعطف خطير بعد
هذه التحركات لقوات الدعم السريع نترقم
نحن هنا في الخرطوم تحركات مكوكيه سواء
كانت داخل القياده العامه للجيش او داخل
قياده الدعم السريع هذا من جانب هنالك بعض
التحركات لبعض الفاعلين الدوليين وذلك
لخلق اجواء من التهدئه بعد حاله الاعتقان
التي سادت الاجواء الامنيه والعسكريه خلال
الساعات الماضيه ربما يكون هنالك تحرك
للفاعلين الدوليين لمنظومه الترويكا لبعض
السفارات هنا في الخرطوم لبعض القوى
السياسيه المكونه المدني القوى الحريه
والتغيير حزب الامه القومي كل هذه القوى
السياسيه الان تنظر بعين الترقب وتتخوف من
ان تنهار العمليه السياسيه التي بدات منذ
الخامس من ديسمبر الماضي بالتالي الان
الكل يترقب ما هي الحلول ما هي مسارات
الحل انفراج هذه الازمه التي وصلت الى
مستوى عالي من الحساسيه بين قياده الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريعه كنت ذكرت لنا في
النشره السابقه ان هناك اجتماع مرتقب بين
الجانبين هل بدا هذا الاجتماع هل هناك
بوادر لاي حل حلالي الازمه الحاصله يعني
حتى اللحظه لم يكون هنالك اي معلومات حول
التوقيت الزماني لانعقاد هذا الاجتماع
اجتماع مجلس الامن والدفاع وهو يضم يضم
القياده العليا في الجيش والمؤسسه الامنيه
والعسكريه والشرطيه وقوات الدعم السريع
هذا الاجتماع من المفترض ان يناقش
الحيثيات والتداعيات والقرارات التي يجب
ان تتخذ لوضع جديد يتعلق بمهام قوات الدعم
السريع خاصه وان هنالك اتفاق سياسي وهنالك
عمليه سياسيه ارتات ان يتم دمج قوات الدعم
السريع عليه فان هذا الاجتماع له اهميه له
حساسيه له درجه من الاهميه لانه سيضع
الامور في نصابها وسيحدد كيف ستمضي الامور
خلال الساعات المقبله خاصه اذا ما اشرنا
الى قوات الدعم السريع كانت قد تلقت
معلومات من قبل الجيش السوداني بضروره ان
يتم الانسحاب من قاعده مروي العسكريه وهو
ما لم يتم حتى اللحظه التي نتحدث فيها طيب
نزار الانباء تتحدث عن مبادرات امميه
واقليميه وجهود تحدث خلف الكواليس هل من
انباء حول ذلك
الان حزب الامه القومي ينشد عبر رئيسه
الجنرال فضل ناصر الرجل الان قال قبل قليل
بانه سيجد وسيبحث اي مسار يفضي الى حلحله
الازمه السياسيه والازمه السودانيه
والازمه الراهنه بين قوات الدعم السريع
وبين الجيش السوداني مساء هذا اليوم ايضا
هنالك منتدى اعلامي لمجموعه المجلس
المركزي بقوه الحريه والتغيير مؤكد بان
الظلال ما حدث يوم امس واليوم بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع سيكون حاضرا
بحسبان ان العمليه السياسيه مرتبطه
ارتباطا وثيقا وجديا بمستوى التفاهمات بين
الجيش وبين قوات الدعم السريع ايضا من
الانباء التي لم تصدر حتى الان بان هنالك
تحركات ربما تكون الاليه الثلاثيه باعتبار
انها ايضا ميسره لعمليه سياسيه ومن
مصلحتها ان تكون الاجواء مهيئه لعقد اتفاق
سياسي بين الفرقه السودانيين